et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
audrey pulvar bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous est adjointe à
la mairie de paris vous êtes tête de
liste aux régionales en ile-de-france
pour plusieurs parties vous êtes
soutenus notamment par le parti
socialiste par le parti radical de
gauche et par place publique et d'autres
partis de gauche également vous êtes
avec nous pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour stéphane
bern et bonjour aux regards tai shan qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france on va commencer
évidemment on va longuement parlé des
régionales audrey pulvar mais d'abord un
mot sur ce tour de france des manuels
macro après le lot il est aujourd'hui
dans la drôme à la rencontre des
restaurateurs notamment qui vont rouvrir
leur salle de restaurant demain ce que
vous dites c'est important qu emmanuel
macron à y prendre le pouls des français
des élus des habitants dans cette
période difficile dans ce début de
sortie de crise sanitaire qui me feront
dessus moi je n'ai pas de commentaire
particulier sur le tour de france du
président il il que ça se passe dans le
nid dans son rôle de président de la
république ya pas confusion des genres
quand même le fait que cette proximité
l'élection le sentiment qu'on a
l'impression d'avoir un président de la
république entre en campagne permanente
je ne suis pas d'un naturel suspicieux
la rencontre elle a lyon on le disait à
la veille des réouvertures des salles de
restaurant la mairie de paris elle a
annoncé la pérennisation des terrasse
éphémère au printemps et à l'été ce sera
du coup pendant la période qui va de
début avril jusqu'à fantôme est ce que
c'est une étape de plus dans la ville
sans voitures voulue par anne hidalgo la
ville avec moins de voitures à la ville
sans voiture parce qu'on sait que
évidemment il y à des usages
incompressibles delà de la voiture ils
sont accompagnés
c'est quand même plus sympathique de
voir des terrasses que de voir des
voitures garées
la plupart des parisiens et des
parisiennes une grande majorité n'ont
pas de véhicule et se déplacera à pied
soit avec les transports en commun
l'enjeu c'est de faire en sorte que ceux
qui ont un usage la capitale au
quotidien pour travailler ou pour leur
agrément puissent y accéder et en sortir
sans difficulté et pour ça il faut
améliorer les dessertes en transports en
commun c'est d'ailleurs un de mes
objectifs en tant que candidate à la
présidence de la région et puis amélioré
aussi tous les équipements du tipa
parkings relais ou multi modalité pour
que la circulation dans la ville mais
quand je dis circulation je ne pense pas
qu'à la voiture je pense aussi à encore
une fois la la circulation des piétons
et puis d autres modes de déplacement
que tout cela se fasse de façon fluide
mais surtout cette mesure elle est non
seulement c'est un c'est un agrément
pour l'oeil et il sait mieux pour le lan
vironnement et la qualité notre ère le
fait qu'ils aient moins de voitures mais
c'est surtout
un coup de pouce pour les restaurateurs
qui à mon sens ce sera le bienvenu je me
souviens très bien de la réaction des
restaurateurs l'année dernière quand
c'est terrasse éphémère ont été
autorisés par la ville de paris à quel
point ça avait été une bouffée d'air
pour les restaurateurs au sortir du
premier grand confinement de 2020 je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nos restaurateurs
ont besoin de soutien ils ont besoin que
nous française et françaises nous les
soutenions à travers nos nos
consommations et puis ils ont besoin que
que les villes et les collectivités les
soutiennent également c'est une bouffée
d'air pour les restaurateurs mes soucis
c'est une fourmi la bouffée d'air pour
les français et les françaises oui il ya
beaucoup de monde
le taux de circulation du virus il est
toujours est constamment en train de
descendre c'est plutôt la bonne nouvelle
est ce que vous redoutez vous n'avez pas
peur quand même en voyant tous ces gens
qui ont envie de se retrouver de refaire
la fête de sortir ce qui est bien
légitime n'ai pas peur de devoir
remonter l'épidémie est ce que pour vous
il ya un risque de reprise possible ou
pas je vais alors je ne suis pas
épidémiologistes mais je crois que nous
sommes tous nous avons tous quelque part
au fond de l'esprit cette inquiétude et
je fais confiance aux français et
singulièrement francilienne et aux
franciliens pour être prudent pris dans
la cheminée alors le la bonne nouvelle
c'est que la vaccination progresse et
que plus nombreux nous serons vacciner
plus il sera facile de contenir le virus
on reste évidemment vigilant par rapport
aux nouveaux variants on reste prudent
les gestes barrière reste de mise donc
évidemment en tant que responsable
public j'incite nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens a continué de pratiquer ces
gestes barrières attention au
relâchement après la première injection
c'est vrai qu'on se sent un peu plus
fort un peu plus protégé mais se vit la
circulation du virus c'est une affaire
personnelle est une affaire collective
quand on se protège on protège les
autres et donc même quand on a été
on a eu sa première injection eh bien on
reste potentiellement voilà sujet enfin
peut on peut être encore contaminé on
peut être contaminants donc il faut
maintenir les gestes barrière
outre l'aspect sanitaire il ya un sujet
qui inquiète le gouvernement à l'issue
de cette crise sanitaire c'est la
question des violences gérald darmanin
et hier il a écrit au préfet parce qu'il
a constaté une augmentation des
violences intrafamiliales de 20% des
violences envers les forces de l'ordre
les services de santé les services de
secours
il a demandé aux préfets des
propositions d'ici demain est ce que
vous redoutez vous aussi les
conséquences de ce confinement de
déconfinement est-ce que ça a provoqué
dans la société
très clairement enfin moi je avec cette
campagne des régionales je rencontre
énormément de d'acteurs de médiateurs
des associatifs des des travailleurs
sociaux des psychologues des infirmiers
infirmières scolaires des responsables
d'associations de lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales et bon c'est
enfoncer des portes ouvertes à grands
coups d'épaulé que de dire qu'il ya eu
une augmentation très forte des
violences intrafamiliales pendant toute
cette année et demie de succession de
confinement couvre-feu déconfinement
mesures de restriction les infirmières
et infirmiers scolaires particulièrement
sont inquiets ont besoin de plus de
moyens de plus effectif de plus de temps
à consacrer aux jeunes il y a évidemment
les violences intrafamiliales faites aux
femmes qui sont un sujet de
préoccupation majeur et sur lequel il
faut continuer travailler
il y a aussi à voir est un travailleur
social que je rencontrais dans les
hauts-de-seine il y a quelques jours me
disais mais vous savez ça va pas être
une quatrième vague ça va être un
tsunami
celui de du mal-être et de la souffrance
d'une grande partie de la jeunesse
française énormément de trauma qui sont
remontés à la surface pour certains
pendant ces périodes difficiles des
violences intrafamiliales qui ont
augmenté des phénomènes de
d'automutilation de dépression de
d'angoise profonde des jeunes qui se
multiplient et il faut impérativement
que nous soyons tous très attentifs à ce
sujet pendant l'année 2020 une grande
partie de la détresse de la jeunesse a
échappé pendant des mois au gouvernement
on s'est longtemps demandé qui était la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
et des universités il a fallu des mois
avant que le gouvernement prenne
conscience de la détresse des étudiants
du fait que des étudiants dépendants de
l'aide alimentaire qu'ils avaient des
difficultés à se loger qu'ils étaient en
situation de dépression profonde
la jallère ge ge alerte sur la situation
des jeunes et des jeunes adolescents des
lycéens qui sont très nombreux à être et
des jeunes très très jeunes aussi un on
nous parle d'enfants de 10 12 ans qui
ont des comportements extrêmement
inquiétant des comportements soit envers
eux mêmes soit 2 d'expression de
souffrance très forte et donc je dis
attention aussi à ce sujet soyons très
vigilants et très à l'écouté des
professionnels de l'enfance et de
l'adolescence et des travailleurs
sociaux qui s'en occupent les régions
gèrent les lycées elles ont un rôle à
jouer dans la formation l'apprentissage
mais au-delà de ça par rapport au
tableau vous nous dresser les caisses
que qu'est ce que la région peut le
faire il
et vous si vous étiez présidente de
région sur quels sur quel levier ce que
vous pourriez agir la région que je
présiderai elle donnera déjà plus de
moyens aux personnels à la communauté
scolaire pour faire face à ces
situations et travaillera avec notamment
les les travailleurs sociaux des
psychologues scolaires les infirmiers
infirmières scolaires on dit souvent
infirmières parce que souvent ce sont
des femmes qui sont des gens le faire
bien sûr l'argent leur horizon et du feu
pour faire en sorte qu'elles jalil et
plus de temps à consacrer aux
adolescents plus de moyens à toutes les
associations qui font de la médiation
plus de moyens évidemment et
d'implantation des missions locales pour
ce qui est peu pour qu'elle puisse être
déployé tous les dispositifs d'aidé
d'accompagnement des jeunes qui sont
exclus très loin de l'emploi qui sortent
de du milieu scolaire sans formation
c'est une prérogative importante majeurs
de la région et puis la région peut
aussi articuler le travail des
départements qui sont en charge de la
préservation de la santé notamment des
collégiens puis des questions de santé
nous proposer des médiateurs dans les
médias dans les lycées ce sera leur rôle
de ces médiateurs et assure un médiateur
dans chaque lycée de france afrique dès
midi que les associations dont celle de
la première mission dont c'est le
travail d'accompagner les jeunes de les
aider de les entendre de les écouter de
porter leur parole de d'entendre c'est
la détresse des parents que ces
associations soient beaucoup plus
soutenu qu'elles aient plus accès
qu'elle est plus d'entrer dans les
établissements scolaires mais les
médiateurs ont proposé les médiateurs
issus d'associations issues
d'associations mais aussi le travail à
soutenir des de tout ce lait tous les
travailleurs sociaux pour lesquels un
certain nombre de financements ont été
baissés que tous les travailleurs
sociaux les infirmières scolaires les
psychologues scolaires et la possibilité
d'avoir moins d'élèves à leur charge et
plus de temps à leur consacrer
ça fait partie des prérogatives de la
région et notamment à travers la
dotation générale de financement des
étapes qui sont même parler des
médiateurs dans les lycées mais voulait
également mettre des moyens
supplémentaires dans les transports oui
notamment avec la présence d'agents de
sécurité dans chaque rame de rer et de
trains
donc ça c'est ça veut dire que ça va
passer par des recrutements est ce que
les sculpter cgt tout 5 alors que ça
représente vraiment premièrement il y
annonce à sa relève aussi en grande
partie des opérateurs
c'est à dire la ratp laisse finalement
il y à déjà aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de d'effectifs qui sont déployés
et qu'il va falloir sensiblement
augmenté parce qu'aujourd'hui à caen 6
francs voyageurs ont voyagé sur 10
disent prendre les transports avec
appréhension est à craindre pour leur
sécurité
quand 100 % des femmes qui utilisent les
transports en commun en ile-de-france
ont été l'objet
souad insultes soit d'agression et
d'agressions parfois criminelle donc
très grave même si ce sont les cas les
plus rares il y a un problème qui n'est
manifestement pas réglé et pas pris à la
hauteur des événements succès
la police régionale des transports
penser c'est le ce sont les services de
sécurité gpsr par exemple pour les
arrêter la ratp le sud où les effectifs
qui sont déjà déployés par la préfecture
de police dont nous voulons qu'ils
augmentent et la région ile-de-france et
la première cliente de l'atp et de la
sncf
elle peut exiger dans les conventions
qu'elles passent avec ces opérateurs des
moyens de sécurité plus important à
dernier arrivé que la dernière ce sont
les cordes de l'aispp la sncf
la dernière fois que valérie pécresse a
demandé qu'ils que ce nombre soit
augmentée là elle a demandé qu'il soit
augmenté de 23 agents c'est largement
insuffisant le rythme du par rapport aux
il faut que nous en discutions avec la
sncf et la ratp aujourd'hui environ 4000
agents de sécurité déployé sur
l'ensemble du réseau
manifestement c'est insuffisant par
ailleurs ma mesure de gratuité des
transports
elle va s'accompagner d'un changement de
mission pour ceux qui jusque là celles
et ceux qui jusque là était dévolu aux
contrôles de la billetterie après
discussions avec les représentants du
personnel après discussion avec les
syndicats et en accord avec eux nous
souhaitons que ces personnes soient
redéployés non pas pour devenir des
agents de sécurité
mais pour devenir des agents de
médiation et et d'apaisement de du vivre
ensemble dans les transports en commun
beaucoup de france il est né de
franciliens qui prennent les transports
se sentent rassurés par la simple
présence d'un agent ratp ou sncf même si
ce n'est pas un agent de sécurité armés
formés pour intervenir mais au moins
c'est quelqu'un qui est référent et qui
peut éventuellement donné l' alerte ou
simplement par sa présence apaiser les
esprits
hamon toujours sur ces questions de
sécurité puisque dans votre programme
vous dites que vous voulez aider les
communes installer la vidéo protection
et les polices municipales voulait les
aider à s'équiper à absorber leurs
agents est-ce que du coup dans le
contexte actuel c'est pas une erreur de
ne pas avoir armés d'armes létales la
police municipale à paris alors là
la décision concernant la bouysse
municipales à paris elle vient d'être
créée pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière lors du conseil de paris
finalement après un travail de quasiment
deux ans et des demandes insistantes de
la maire de paris en la matière puisque
la création de cette police municipale
nécessitait une modification de la loi
et puis le processus est très longue
formation extérieur donc cette police
elle vient d'être créée elle est armée
n'est par mail et allemands mais elle
est armée est là des moyens sécurisante
excision manifestement c'est suffisant
pour la police municipale parisienne
c'est en tout cas
l'arbitrage qui a été rendu par la maire
de paris la situation n'est pas
forcément la même dans paris et dans le
reste de l'île de france
ce que nous voulons ce que je veux en
tant que présidente de région assez de
pouvoir accompagner les mères qui n'ont
pas encore de police municipale ou ceux
qui souhaitent mieux formés voire pour
certains un milan police municipale et
pouvoir les accompagner financièrement
mais d'avoir une maison droit de la de
france où il faut qu'à soir mais pour
vous sa dialyse il y à des endroits
d'île de france où certains maires y
compris des maires de gauche je pense à
à mathieu hanotin par exemple à à saint
denis ont fait le choix
pas par conviction mais par pragmatisme
d'armes et leur police parce qu'ils ont
constaté qu'il y avait une défaillance
en termes d'effectifs et d'équipements
de la police nationale dont celle dont
c'est la mission évidemment protéger les
citoyens lutter contre le grand
banditisme lutter contre les grands
trafics
mais quand vous êtes maire d'une ville
comme saint denis que vous avez une
situation d'insécurité très forte que
les effectifs de police nationale ne
sont pas suffisants pas suffisamment
déployés et pas suffisamment équipés
plutôt que d'attendre que enfin le
gouvernement remplit ses obligations
envers les citoyens y compris et
tunisien les données dionysienne vous
faites le choix c'est le choix qui a été
fait par mathieu hanotin et par son
conseil municipal d'art mais la police
initialement remplit pas ses obligations
en maître absolu rites et notamment
celle ci dessous du bras mais mais pas
seulement seine saint denis c'est le cas
aussi à paris ce n'est pas de ce n'est
pas du ressort de la police municipale
qu'elles soient armés ou pas de régler
la question des trafics de drogue dans
le dit
même dans le 19e arrondissement par
exemple ce n'est pas du ressort de la
police municipale qu'elle soir nous pas
de régler les questions de grand
banditisme de trafic
german ans il dit qu'il ya eu la guerre
aux trafics de noix à écouter les
résultats sont quand même assez peu
probants qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que les
collectivités paris ou la région peut
faire de plus notamment sur la question
spécifique du trafic de drogue que vous
venez d'évoquer le trafic de drogue à
paris les quartiers qui sont c'est une
compétence de la police nationale mais
je ma question qu'est ce que les
collectivités peuvent faire de plus ou
en accompagnement ou en complément
est ce que nous nous proposons c'est que
le ministre de l'intérieur prenne ses
responsabilités que le gouvernement
prenne ses responsabilités et qui lutte
efficacement contre les trafics
d'enfants ça ne ça ne relève pas
pardonnez moi mais ça ne relève pas
d'une police municipale ça ne relève pas
de la région après évidemment une
régions comme l'ile-de-france à un
certain nombre de moyens de moyens de
coordination et de moyens de médiation
tous les moyens de se forma tion donc il
ya des possibilités d'initiative et de
demandes fortes à l'égard du
gouvernement
mais avant tout c'est au gouvernement et
au ministre de l'intérieur d' assurer le
train la lutte contre le trafic des
drogues de après encore une fois sur la
question de l'aménagement l'aménagement
des villes sur l'aménagement des villes
sur l'aménagement des quartiers sur la
présence le déploiement de d'une police
municipale ou d'agents de médiation et
de et qui permettent encore une fois de
pacifier l'espace public
les villes les collectivités la région
ont leur rôle à jouer je viens de vous
en parler mais quand même que par la
main de chacun fasse que chacun mais pas
seulement je vous ai parlé de plusieurs
choses mais que chacun fasse son métier
et pardonnez moi ce n'est pas à une
présidente de région d'assurer
le démantèlement de réseaux de trafic de
drogue un dernier mot sur votre
proposition phare en tout cas celle qui
figure en tête de votre programme n'en a
pas encore parlé dans c'est la gratuité
c'est la gratuité des transports alors
vous l'avez entendu un an durant cette
campagne évidemment toutes les questions
qui se posent autour du financement de
cette mesure et notamment de comment
vous allez financer du coup
l'investissement dans les transports
comment vous répondez à ces critiques
déjà je vous réponds que la billetterie
donc ce qu'on l'on va supprimer c'est à
dire le fait pour les usagers les
voyageurs les voyageuses de payer leur
passe navigo leur ticket à l'unité
c'est une des sept finance le
fonctionnement et non l'investissement
ce sont deux postes complètement séparée
donc l'investissement dans les nouvelles
lignes dans le matériel roulant dans de
nouvelles dessertes dans d une
amélioration du réseau et de sa sécurité
cet investissement il a reste pérenne
garantie et nous allons même l'augmenter
la billetterie ne finance pas
l'investissement
donc on peut faire la gratuité et
continuer l'investissement la
billettique la billetterie finances du
fonctionnement
la première des choses que je voudrais
vous redire sur la cas la question de la
gratuité des transports
c'est que c'est une mesure de pouvoir
d'achat pour les plus modestes pour les
jeunes pour les parents qui ont
plusieurs enfants à la maison et qui
n'ont pas 350 euros par an et par enfant
et par adolescents pour payer les
déplacements dans les transports c'est
une mesure de justice sociale parce que
justement elle s'est toujours accompagné
la gratuité des transports d'une
augmentation de l'offre d'une
amélioration de la desserte et c'est
donc pour nous un objectif majeur de
pouvoir desservir l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france de façon cohérente entre
le rail le tramway le bus les navettes
bien sûr une partie de circulation
automobile et le
le vélo bien sûr et ne pas oublier qu'il
y a quand même 60 % de déplacement
aujourd'hui en une défense ils se font à
pied
donc il faut arriver à interconnecter et
à sécuriser l'ensemble de ses moyens de
déplacement donc ça va au delà des
transports c'est une question de
mobilité pour que cette mesure de la
gratuité prenne tout son sens et puis
c'est évidemment une mesure de
responsabilité à l'égard de l'urgence
climatique parce qu'il nous faut
transformer nos modes de transport et
notre mobile du coup comment vous
expliquer qu'elle ne trouve pas plus
d'écho cette mesure julien bayou julien
bayou et magasins ou qualité à votre
place il nous est dit non non je suis
mais parce que la gagnante est trop
sympa leur manque d'ambition et
peut-être parce qu'il ne prend pas assez
les transports en commun comme moi je
les prends à toute heure de la journée
et singulièrement très tôt le matin et
en début de soirée quand les premières
lignes on vont travailler quand elles
quittent leur domicile pour aller
travailler vous savez quand il est 5h 45
5h45 heure cinquante cinq ou six heures
15 en provenance au départ de gare saint
lazare en provenance ou au départ de
gare du nord ou de gare de lyon vous
avez des trains des rer qui arrivent ou
qui partent bondé de travailleurs et
travailleuses de première ligne pour qui
un abonnement navigo gratuit fera une
très grande différence
et puis peut-être que julien bayou ne
parle pas assez à ces jeunes de
seine-saint-denis d'essonne des yvelines
ou encore du val d'oise que je rencontre
régulièrement et qui se sentent assigné
à résidence parce que pour eux payer
deux euros 54 euros 10 euros
l'aller-retour pour ou pas seulement
aller à paris mais passer par exemple
dans le département voisin
et bien c'est pour eux une très grande
difficulté et une sensation d'injustice
ya énormément de francilienne et de
franciliens qui sont pour cette mesure
de la gratuité des transports nous
l'avons fait tester 75% des français à
paris en petite et en grande couronne
sont pour la gratuité à me dire que ça
sera une condition sinequanone cette
mesure d'un rapprochement éventuel ce
que de vos listes vous ne l'abandonné
pas si un accord entre votre
il s'assoit à condition que cette mesure
figure dans le programme le 20 juin
les franciliennes et les franciliens qui
voteront pour la liste ile-de-france en
commun voteront pour la gratuité des
transports
ça c'est le premier tour il n'y a aucune
raison que le 27 juin je ne continue pas
de leur proposer la gratuité des
transports
ma candidature c'est un référendum pour
la gratuité des transports vous t il de
france en commun vous votez pour la
gratuité des transports et encore une
fois cette gratuité des transports
elle nie pas exclusive ni de la sécurité
ni de la qualité nous ferons les trois à
la fois je rappelle simplement que nous
voulons faire cette gratuité
progressivement tout au long du mandat
qu'on commence le 1er septembre par la
gratuité pour les moins de 18 ans sur
l'ensemble de la région et pas seulement
à paris comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
et pour les 18 25 ans en parcours
d'insertion demandeurs d'emploi ou
étudiants et pour c'est pour ces
personnes pour ces centaines de milliers
de personnes qui dès le 1er septembre ne
paieront plus leur passe navigo ou ne
paieront plus de tickets à l'unité ça
fera une très grande différence donc que
ce soit bien clair pour les gens qui
nous regardent et qui ont peut-être vos
électeurs le soir du 20 juin vous
travaillez déjà un accord avec julien
bayou nous ont menti notin pas encore à
100 mais vous l'envisagez selon votre
résultat ou pas nous l'envisageons si
clémentine autain et julien bayou
s'accordent sur une gratuité des
transports et les reprises s'accordent
sur nos valeurs et sur notre programme
et la gratuité des transports ont fait
en fait pas et un mot sur jean l'ordre
mélenchon ah oui sur jean luc mélenchon
s'est alors il y aura la paix la
perspective des alliances et des
négociations de second tour est ce que
vous aurez besoin la france a soumises
pour gagner éventuellement au deuxième
tour et est ce que vous pouvez vous
rapprocher la france est soumise après
les propos de jean-luc mélenchon qui
font qu'ils font polémique mais je comme
je voulais répondu à l'instant nous nous
serons en tête des forces de gauche au
soir du 20 juin
j'en ai certes j'en suis absolument
persuadé parce que d'icesave h pour le
moment de répit demain à bon vous avez
vu les derniers sondages vous en avez
oui d'abord on a commandé un ensuite le
dernier sondage sondages et lab nous
mettait en tête des forces de gauche et
il y goube allemand si vous regardez
l'ensemble des sondages depuis huit mois
voilà le gagner donnez moi
pardonnez moi soyons un peu sérieux si
vous regardez l'ensemble des sondages
depuis septembre dernier et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui la liste ile-de-france en
commun arrive régulièrement en tête des
sondages
et c'est le cas en tout cas du tout
dernier willy sauvetage l'indiquent les
sondages qui les relient les sondages
les français c'est être sûr de gagner
sur la question la question ne se pose
pas aujourd'hui dit toujours dit que
j'étais pour l'union entre le premier et
le second tour sur notre programme sur
nos valeurs ce qui se retrouve seront
les bienvenus vous me parlez des propos
de jean luc mélenchon les propos de
jean-luc mélenchon ont profondément
choqué à juste titre toutes celles et
ceux qui les ont entendus ils lisent à
lui même je crois a demandé hier en
parlant de sa compassion à l'égard des
familles des victimes c'est aux familles
des victimes que je pense et je ne crois
pas que dans notre démocratie que dans
notre république il y un système
politique qui organisent des attentats
terroristes ceux qui organisent des
attentats terroristes ce sont les
assassins c'est l'assassin le tueur de
toulouse qui a tué sept personnes en
2012 trois soldats qui en a qui a blessé
grièvement un quatrième soldat qui garde
des séquelles très lourde à vis de cet
attentat ce sont évidemment le sait
évidemment jonathan sengler gabriel et
arié solaire qui ont été tuées et mejia
ben mau cenego qui ont un kia qui a été
tué gabriel marié et myriam avait 3 6
ans et 8 ans je ne crois pas que dans
notre république il ya un système
politique qui cyniquement organise ce
genre de d'attac qui n'ont évidemment
rien sinon le terrorisme
ce n'est pas un incident ils n'arrivent
pas incidemment c'est un projet de man
qui vise notre république est évidemment
nous sommes tous et toutes je crois
debout pour défendre la république et
donc toutes celles et ceux qui se
retrouvent dans ces valeurs là qui se
retrouveront dans notre programme sont
les bienvenus pour nous rejoindre
et pour battre valérie pécresse le 27
juin justin tout dernièrement puisque
lyon il y en a beaucoup parlé de cet
épisodeà et gérald darmanin qui vous a
tendu la main vous lui avez répondu vous
l'avez rencontré le médecin intérêts non
je n'ai pas rencontré le ministre de
l'intérieur d'abord parce qu'il n'a pas
dit qu'il renonçait à son intention de
déposer plainte mais l'appât du gain est
encore ou paris il n'habite milla il n'a
pas dit qu'il renonçait à déposer
plainte à mon égard et moi je ne vais
pas un entretien pour m'expliquer où
pour me justifier mes informations il
n'a pas déposé plainte nous sommes par
ailleurs en période de réseaux réserve
ministérielle donc effectivement j'ai
reçu de la part du ministre et je l'en
remercie des propositions de rencontre
mais sans une annonce claire de sa part
qu'il renonce à porter plainte et il me
semble pas opportun de le rencontrer et
encore moins en période de réserve
ministérielle à quelques jours
d'élections
il me semble que gérald darmanin
d'autres sujets à traiter et puisqu'on
parlait de jean-luc mélenchon à
l'instant les l'appel au meurtre contre
des militants de gauche qui a été
diffusé et relayée et qui le fait normal
le déliement de l'extrême droite me
semble de nature à nous inquiéter et je
pense que ça occupe aussi le ministre de
l'intérieur beaucoup plus que ma petite
personne
mais c'est tant mieux si beaucoup merci
on aurait pu le voir d'avoir essayé
notre invité ce matin en regardant une
nouvelle france ses fans ses lampes et
12 à alan +12 à ces migrants confiné à
l'abri des regards c'est à la une de
ouest france ce matin merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]